it's not just the notebook and after I
want to eliminate my competition and
become number one I don't care what it
takes I will beat Nia by any means
necessary hello and welcome to Death
Note 101 series that breaks down
everyone and everything in the Death
Note world and today we are going to be
taking a look at the hot headed
detective of the wammy's house orphanage
melot melot real name Michael keel is
one of the two children from the
orphanage Rama's house who were chosen
as successors to the legendary detective
known as Oh mellow Sports combed yellow
hair dresses in clothing primarily made
out of leather and is often seen norming
on chocolate which is a nod to else
habit of eating sweets of all kinds at
an unknown age Mello was taken into
wammy's house where he would start
studying hard and soon become known as
the second smartest kid within the
entire institution with the only person
trumping him being a younger child names
Nia who would become a rival in Miller's
eyes it's important to note that this
was a Miller's eyes because Nia did not
see things the same way
however Mello worked harder than anyone
on a quest to become the best due to
Nia's natural intelligence he would
always emerge victorious however one day
Mello and Nia was summoned to the office
of Roger OVA the manager of wammy's
house and they were told of L's passing
to which Mello reacted quite
aggressively he started shouting and
demanding information about what had
happened which introduced the audience
to the fact that even though he is one
of the most intelligent characters in
the entire series Miller does have a
tendency of letting emotions govern his
actions quite frequently leading to some
violent outbursts and when informs that
L hadn't had the time to pick either one
as his successor Roger asked if near and
Mello would be amenable to working
together in order to catch Elle's
murderer Kira however Mello dismissed
this notion instantly and claimed that
near should be the ones take up the
mantle of Elle stating that he was the
more reasonable and intelligent of the
two however this was merely a vehicle to
separate himself to take up the Kira
case in his own way not so much to catch
the killer or even to avenge oh but out
of sheer desire to prove that he could
solve the case before Nia Mello then
left wammy's house and moved to the
United States where he would dwell for
four years forming connections with the
Mafia and proceeding to locate and
dispose of multiple underground leaders
that even Kira was incapable of killing
it would be these and future actions
that really highlighted the stark
contrast between Elle near and Mello as
due to his explosive nature Mello is
also not content with simply observing
and analyzing a situation like near oil
but instead
he insisted on engaging in constant
action designed to bring him closer to
his goals and where the former - were
willing to relentlessly pursue a case
more or less within the bounds of the
law Melo was ready and willing to break
every rule be at legal or moral in order
to defeat Nia and this is epitomized
when Melo eventually managed to get his
hands on a Death Note and proceeded to
use it to kill members of the SPK
an organization led directly by Nia
although what's worse is that he didn't
perform this as any form of action to
catch Kira but rather in an effort to
prevent his rival from doing so but that
said Mello certainly isn't a completely
cold-hearted killer which was shown when
he did feel sorry for Soichiro Yagami
when he was fatally shot and even later
in the story went his friend Matt dies
which occurred as a direct result of
Miller's actions speaking of we don't
really know much about the relationship
between Melo and Matt but it seems as if
they were close friends during their
childhood as Matt was also raised in
wammy's house and he is actually one of
if not the only person that Mello keeps
close to him and actually values as a
friend however Matt was not Miller's
only acquaintance in this world as even
though Melo possessed a deep hatred
towards his own perceived rival Nia he
did also have great respect for him and
provided him with a lot of useful
information later proving
extraordinarily vital in Kira's downfall
for example he informed NIR about the
concepts of the Shinigami at the death
note and the to fake rules that were
written in one of the death notes and
these facts helped near immensely as he
became certain that Kira was a member of
the Japanese task force and set his
sights on by alchemy as the series went
on though MELAS aggressive methods would
generate several key setbacks such as
having been threatened at gunpoint
having his hideouts found and destroyed
as well as Mela having to self-destruct
one while he was still inside because of
this he acquired a large scar on the
left side of his face towards the end of
the series but even with this misfortune
he never lost his dedication and
willingness to fight for his admittedly
primarily selfish goals and in this
effort Mello would come to kidnap Kira
spokeswoman Kiyomi Takada however whilst
captive taka died was able to kill
Miller by writing his name on a piece of
death note she had with her before
proceeding to get killed herself with
another death note by light
however Miller's actions would prove
vital in taking down Kira as toccatas
kidnapping led to one of Kira's
followers accidentally revealing
information to nia which eventually
culminated in Kira's defeat although it
is debatable whether Mello knew his
actions were necessary in order for cure
to be caught or if he was simply and
purely working towards his own goals the
entire time in the end near noted that
Melo was one of the most integral
elements in closing the Cure case and
that to get
they had surpassed L and following the
death of Light Yagami
Nia officially became the next L and to
Shirin eating chocolate at the end of
the series as a sign of respect towards
Miller small fun facts about Miller
mellows clothing was based entirely on
the kind of fashion that the illustrator
of Death Note Takeshi Obata enjoyed
drawing the most in a shocking potential
turn of events originally Melo was
supposed to be the one who would defeat
white however this plan eventually
changed due to the idea that Mellors
knowledge concerning the Death Note
would have made it far too easy for him
thus making the finale much less intense
while Melo was absent from the Death
Note live-action films elders consumed
several chocolates as a note to the
character melos death was only showing
very briefly in both the anime and the
manga due to concerns if it was
presented in a more drastic manner it
could have potentially spoiled the
meaning and significance of the demise
Mello is interestingly enough the only
one of the three detectives from Riley's
house who investigated the Kira case and
never met Light Yagami in person and
finally a truly useless fact amongst the
Death Note fanbase there are rumors
speculating that Madonna cos played
mellow for her music video jump although
this has never being confirmed thus
making it a piece of exceptionally
useless knowledge and that pretty much
does it for Mello if you enjoyed this
video and the content this channel
produced in general and please do
consider donating to the new world
review patreon because the support of
all the amazing people is what continues
to make this channel possible and if
patreon isn't quite your style then
please do leave this video a like share
or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan retakes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
who what or where you'd like to see
featured on the next death note 101
you